ce n'est pas la bière c'est du ter je
salue à toutes et à tous je suis très
très heureux de vous retrouver pour ce
5ème grand labo live organisés sur un
thème différent de ceux des fois
précédentes on a voulu changer un petit
peu j'ai eu la chance de faire des live
avec mathilde maillard de bien dans ma
thèse à deux occasions des live qui ont
été assez bien suivi merci à vous toutes
et tous de l'est d'ottawa reçues vicedo
live sur la thèse de manière voilà très
très intense beaucoup de commentaires
beaucoup de partage on aimerait que ce
soit la même chose cette fois-ci pour ce
nouveau live avec une personnalité de
marque sur un thème très différents je
dédie celui des livres de science et
cette personnalité qui est avec nous
c'est elodie chabrol salut elodie salut
bonjour à tous salut m comment ça va ça
va très bien ça va très bien on ce
samedi à la maison à la maison restée
confinée c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
organise ses live c'est que ça permet à
tout à chacun de faire quelque chose
d'un peu différent de ce qui se fait
d'habitude peut-être proposer de façon
peut-être un peu divertissante on essaye
de parler de choses importantes sérieuse
et parmi ces choses importantes ces
choses sérieuses mais il ya les livres
de science c'est vraiment une passion
pour beaucoup d'entre vous la science et
des médiums privilégié c'est bien sûr
les livres et quand on parle de livres
bien sûr il le dit on parle pas
simplement de monographies on parle pas
simplement de deux romans mais deux
romans de science-fiction par exemple de
bande de bandes dessinées etc
et donc c'est de ça dont on va parler
avec à la tienne avec plusieurs invités
est ce que tu peux d'abord nous parler
un petit peu de ton actualité
avant de parler des livres que toi tu as
choisi puis des invités que tu as que tu
as aussi choisi avec moi quelques mots
de d'elodie chabrol et de pinch of
sciences
alors bye 100 normalement c'est en mai
bien sûr vous comme vous vous doutez
tout seul on a dû décaler ça ça sera du
coup du 7 au 9 septembre
si tout va bien croisons les doigts
parce que bon vu la situation
actuellement peut pas vraiment prêt dia
au pire du pire si jamais on doit
vraiment
affaire payne docents dans les bars qui
serait un petit peu très triste on le
ferait en live on se débrouillera met
donc voilà non même monde du 7 au 9
septembre donc
donc voilà là on est un petit peu en
pause c'est on essaye de dures gérer ça
c'est du connu que le toit habitués à
faire de l'événementiel souvent c'est
hyper dur et puis surtout en fait donc
j'ai créé par une toxine france que je
dirige mais je suis aussi la directrice
internationale de pines
et ça ça m'a fait avoir deux semaines de
cauchemar alors fin février-début début
mars
parce qu'en fait au tout début de la
crise on savait pas exactement où on
allait en être
qu'est ce qui allait se passer et du
coup il a fallu prendre la décision en
tout cas de la date possible du report
et du potentiel report à l'époque où il
y avait encore plein de pays pour
lesquels ça allait et même en france ça
aller où on se disait ça se trouve on va
reporter et puis on met en fête tout ira
bien et on va du coup un peu regretté ce
report
bon maintenant je suis contente qu'on
ait pris cette décision là prix super
taux n'est anticipée
c'est bien d'avoir anticipé mais
j'aurais presque aimé que le mois de
maintenant on m'envoie un petit pigeon
voyageur et me disent en fait c'est trop
le chaos c'est pas la peine de stressé
parce que du coup c'est vrai que ne pas
savoir c'était très très dur de se dire
ça se trouve je reporte tout un festival
il ya énormément de bénévoles d'ailleurs
que je remercie à qui du coup au passage
qui bossent sur paint opsens que ce soit
en france et dans le monde
et du coup c'est vrai que je voulais pas
reportées si par hasard et parmi ces
bénévoles au maître ya matic de maya
alors on va parler de ceux de ce live
spécial good book ce juste une petite
phrase pour vous dire que good book
c'est un nouveau format qu'on va
diffuser qu'on va commencer à diffuser
avec maxime de santos qui met beaucoup
énormément même sur ce format de vidéo
il s'agit de suivre une personnalité de
la communication du tablier risation
scientifique dans une librairie la
librairie mollat pour aller voir au gré
de ses découvertes improvisé ce qu'ils
aiment lire ce que cette personnalité
aime lire ce qu'elle aime moins lire ses
coups de gueule ses coûts de ses coudes
déception le premier épisode a été
diffusé c'est didier pourquery de nos
conversations qui nous a fait le plaisir
d'être de participer au ce ce numéro un
d'autres tournages sont prévus bien sûr
même effet que pour paris turf saillants
des tournages ont été décalés il ya
plein de super youtuber de super
journalistes scientifiques ont accepté
de tourner des goudes books donc ça sera
tourné probablement plus tôt cet été est
donc diffusé plus tôt en septembre
octobre
mais en attendant un peu un peu là aussi
pour patienter on a voulu organiser ce
live donc spécial good book et on a la
possibilité de d'écouté des
personnalités qu'on va recevoir d'aidé
youtuber de youtube avant ça toi elodie
ce que tu es une grosse consommatrice de
livres ou est ce que parce que tu fais
15 mille trucs autant de temps que tu
voudrais est bien plutôt la deuxième
possibilité est effectivement j'en ai
plein j'ai une liste d'attentes de
bouquins énorme mais c'est vrai que je
passe ma journée gm sont à lire de la
science donc j'essaye d'alterner les
bouquins de sciences et les bouquins
d'autres choses les romans les trucs un
petit peu différent du coup j'en ai pas
mal et c'est vrai que typiquement dans
le métro je suis sur twitter le soir je
suis sur twitter j'ai un peu du mal à
décrocher et à me poser il ya donc je
lis beaucoup en vacances en 7 oui tout
ça c'est quand tu arrives là déconnecté
finalement way exactement c'est
généralement bouquin de ces enjeux les
enfile et là je peux en les lire
vraiment rapidement et je profite quoi
alors on va on va dans quelques instants
voir ta sélection à toi je vois d'abord
que tu nous annonce les invités que tu
as choisie avec moi il y en a 5 on a
beaucoup de chance
tout à fait on a eu on a eu beaucoup de
chance on a des gens vraiment chouette
qui viennent de disciplines différentes
qui vont du coup vous nous a apporté des
points de vue et des idées de bouquins
un petit peu d'un peu partout avec avec
du coup des domaines bien bien différent
alors par d'apparition va avoir nathan 8
haendel du chat sceptiques
marit reiber de la boîte à curiosité les
nguyen nguyen hoang pardon de saint anne
faurot clotide chamussy de passer
sauvage et lorca roseau du podcast
science infuse voilà donc des gens qui
connaissent bien la vulgarisation
scientifique et laiteries contente oui
je suis content parce que si tu es
contente lui content si carly je me dis
qu'on va avoir
on va avoir des discussions super
intéressante a effectué ensuite sur les
i oui pardon
ouais non j'allais dire et bien sûr
toutes celles et ceux qui nous regardent
bien sûr partie
j'ai vos propres pelé vos propres goûts
propres coups de coeur poser des
questions à nos invités et on sera très
sont très contents de pouvoir y répondre
et on commence par ta sélection good
books
elodie alors ma sélection good book ça
je vais commencer pas tu mourras moins
bête de mario le tome numéro 5 alors moi
c'est vrai que comme je disais tout à
l'heure
généralement je le lis les bouquins en
vacances ou en tout cas quand je
déconnecte donc c'est vrai que mes
critères ça va être un bouquin les
bouquins plutôt cool est facile et drôle
ouais voilà j'ai besoin que ça m'amuse
pas c'est là pour le coup c'est drôle et
alors là celui-là il est alors donc
c'est tout ça c'est le tome 5 de toute
une collection de marion montaigne pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas marion
montaigne
elle écrit donc cdc des bd de science ce
qui est assez fantastique avec mario
montagne c'est que elle n'a pas de
limites sur l'humour donc on peut
retrouver du enfin vraiment s est elle
se lâche
elle n'hésite pas à mettre des
références un peu drôle à à se moquer un
peu ce parfois de certains chanteurs
certains chaîne de télé 2 voilà deux
personnes politiques certains hommes
politiques
en gros elle a vraiment un humour
parfois un peu gras que j'adore mais ce
qui est génial c'est quand en gros donc
chaque chapitre dans chaque chapitre va
prendre une idée de sciences et puis
elles valent expliquer alors ce qui est
génial c'est que c'est forcément ce
n'est pas blindé de faits scientifiques
etc
c'est suffisamment scientifique pour
vraiment être coulés et donner un peu d
infos tout en ayant beaucoup d'humour de
dessins de machins et moi perso
généralement les gens savent que je suis
en train de dire ça parce que je suis
dans un coin en train de bouffer tout
seul non maintenant cheikh ccsa son
génie finalement allier la science qui
par définition plutôt austère sérieuse
avec des schémas très rigoureux les
représentations très rigoureuse way a de
l'humour parfois graveleux et c'est
assumé cse c'est ce mélange détonnant
qui fait que marion montaigne et unique
exactement c'est unique c'est génial
donc effectivement avec moi parce que
dans la combe pas alors que moi c'est le
premier que j'ai lu d'ailleurs le voile
à l'accord
et j'ai découvert marion montaigne avec
ça alors cette bd jeu les gars je les ai
achetés il ya hyper longtemps je les
gardais très très longtemps parce que
j'ai pas trouvé le moment où me mettre
dedans est en fait un dimanche je me
suis dit ok je coupe tout je me pose je
me suis fait un thermos de thé
j'étais au lit avec ma bd est pareil
geler les l'élu en 2h quoi je suis sorti
de là à mme dia a mais c'était tellement
génial je viens de vivre un moment
fantastique et c'est pour ça qu'à noël
du coup j'ai demandé le tome 5 est
depuis en fait j'ai acheté le taux les
autres voilà je pars en fait du tome 5
et je fait petit à petit je vais
retourner vers le tome 1
donc voilà c'est ça qui est vraiment
génial c'est drôle il ya de l'actualité
dans le tome 5 ce qui était assez
marrant c'est que notamment il ya un
chapitre sur pourquoi sur les pigeons
voyageurs
pigeon versus corbeau parce que dans
game of thrones on voit des corbeaux
voyageurs donc du coup elle a un petit
peu elle est un petit peu discuté de
pourquoi le corbeau pourquoi pourquoi le
pigeon est ce que le signe serait aussi
un bon et un bon animal pour pour faire
passer les messages
donc il ya des trucs comme ça les
questions super pertinente en fait
messieurs les questions etc qui poserait
un gamin de 57 ans et ben voilà donc moi
gamine de cinq ans je me suis posé ça
comme je regardais game of non puisqu'on
puisqu'on parle de marion elle quand
elle a une production d'un gars marion
c'est qu'elle produit beaucoup elle a
d'ailleurs sorti entend parler à pour
préparer ce live live alors ça retient
un billet sur la transpiration on va
mettre le lien dans le chat pour vous
puissiez regarder cette bd fait en
confinement sur la transpiration c'est
juste génial ce que propose de passer au
deuxième livre ouais elodie est venu
avec mon deuxième livre je tiens à dire
que je l'avais choisie avant que
clotilde ne valide sa présence retour
vers le palais au donc je ne dis pas ça
parce que clotilde est notre invité mais
comme l'a écrit dedans
et ouais exactement
elle est une des auteures donc ce
bouquin en fait ce sont cinq
vulgarisateur qui se sont mis en équipe
qui s'appelle lattes palais du couple
car ça aboutit à clotilde chamussy ya
jennifer garner marion sabourdy pierre
karner et aurélie bordeneuve qui elle a
fait les illustrations est alors encore
une fois ce bouquin alors bon je vais
pas vous avoue je vais pas vous mentir
je les lui sur une plage en grèce du
coup il ya un petit souvenir qui va avec
associer forcément soleil et de vacances
mais il était génial parce que je trouve
que ils prennent un sujet qui peut être
un petit peu voilà un petit peu
difficile la préhistoire qui est pas
forcément voilà on peut se dire bon ok
c'est pas très funky à dire sur la
préhistoire
qu'est ce qu'il a à dire sur la
préhistoire voilà on a déjà tout entendu
et bah non en fait ils ont rendu la
paire histoire sexy drôle moi perso j'ai
lu ce bouquin j'ai eu envie d'aller
vivre pendant la préhistoire où on lit
que ils ont des tatouages que ils ont
des sextoys vraiment gelé sur wii et
puis surtout ils ont réussi le tour
vraiment le tour de main de réussir à
avoir le même humour super décapant tout
le long du livre ça oui c'était une
vraie unité quoi une vraie unité travers
tous les ouvrages même si c'est un truc
collectif
exactement c'est un truc collectif ya
une belle unité c'est drôle
j'avais l'impression parfois de
retrouver un peu père karner marion que
je connais dans certaines phrases dont
certains très loose et abidal je vois
donc voilà c'est vraiment un super
bouquin wilma il m'a vraiment bien fait
rire et puis surtout on apprend plein de
choses sur ce qui s'est passé pendant la
préhistoire sur ce qu'ils avaient à
l'époque sur le fait que bayaoui la
bière peut-être n'est pas tout jeune
vraiment voilà plein plein de choses qui
au final sont surprenantes
et puis super bien écrits de quoi bon
bah c'est super merci pour cette petite
sélection je te propose de prendre ces
tops j'adore en plus
marion montaigne dont je suis content
que tu t'es choisi marion alors juste
parce qu'une question dans live
extrêmement importante
valentin me demande d'où de science de
la science sonore salut valentin
pourquoi jeter plus de cheveux alors que
là bas comme tout le monde j'ai la coupe
replay parce que les coiffeurs battue
peut plus y aller voilà maintenant on
passe sur dossiers suivants
et je te propose d'accueillir alors bien
sûr on remet dans l'est le chat un les
liens vers tu mourras moins bête tome 5
de marion montaigne est de retour à
l'eau paléo de de la team paléo et
d'autre les toute l'équipe du café des
sciences et notamment enfin cocoa
merrion ça pour dire on vous remet tous
ces liens dans dans le chat et l'heure
est venue elodie d'accueillir notre
premier invité alors est ce que tu peux
le redire pour toutes celles et ceux qui
nous rejoignent
nathan 8 endel qui est salut nathan de
chats sceptiques
bonjour ça va la tenter moustache
alors attendez j'ai juste coupé je
suivais sur la chaîne youtube et je
réalise qu'il ya un petit décalage en
fait donc voilà j'ai coupé youtube comme
ça je vous regarde gestion zoom sa
lunette un super micro déjà je suis très
jaloux le mien gecas
mais on s'entend bien c'est l'essentiel
surmontant des signes axa moi je vais
pas tarder à temps comment ça se passe
de ton côté avant de nous parler de
sélection
sorry je t'ai pas écoutez mathieu et
comme on commence comment ça va de ton
côté
malgré le confinement et avant de parler
de la sélection et les plumes plus bas
ça se passe bien écoute je pense que
quelque chose qui finalement être
beaucoup avec ce confinement
c'est le fait qu'il ya du beau temps
parce que même si on est enfermé et
qu'on peut pas sortir en tout cas pas
sortir beaucoup le fait d'avoir dû voter
en extérieur c est quand même car il a
bossé un peu oui mais fondamentalement
je crois que pour les gens pour les
youtuber en général le fait qu'ils
confinement ou pas à moins qu'il y ait
des choses aller filmer à l'extérieur ça
ne change pas tellement leur quotidien
moi personnellement j'ai de la chance
c'est que cette histoire de confinement
n'a pas vraiment beaucoup perturbé mon
quotidien est ce que tu veux nous parler
de tes livres alors melli premier livre
est peut-être le premier livre les deux
livres que j'ai sélectionné deux dont
j'ai décidé de vous parler alors le tout
premier livre c'est je vais essayer de
le montrer devenez savant devenait
sorcier et c'est en fait mon premier
livre sceptique c'est mon premier livre
d'esprit critique et lorsqu est très
drôle c'est que il m'a été offert
c'était en 2004 il
été offert par ma grand mère qui n'était
pas une sceptiques qui était plutôt une
personne qu'ils croyaient en des choses
comme comme l'astrologie en des tas de
choses et c'est eric et compagnie et
donc c'est très rigolo que je réalise
aujourd'hui des années plus tard qu'en
2004 elle m'a offert un livre d'esprit
critique et je suis pas sûr qu'elle ait
réalisé elle même ce qu'elle est mais ce
qui est certain c'est que ce livre a été
vraiment formateur pour moi parce que ça
a été du haut de mes 16 ans à l'époque
où j'ai reçu ça c'est la première fois
que j'avais un ouvrage de ce type là
dans les mains et c'est un ouvrage
duquel j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
c'est cet ouvrage ça a été ma première
confrontation à des questions par
exemple devra de radioactivité à des
questions de métaphysique avec pas de
métaphysique à des question de comment
est ce qu'on dit quand deux personnes
sont reliés mentalement encore le terme
j'ai oublié de te dire comme elodie et
moi j'ai pu le terme technique en mai à
distance quand deux personnes sont liées
mentalement à distance comment est ce
que c'est ça voilà ce livre a été ma
première qu'on allait pas les
scientifiques mais qu à des questions de
télépathie à toutes sortes de
connaissances diverses et variées à
l'astrologie au principe de la pari
d'owlient pari d'owlient pour ceux qui
ne connaissent pas le mot c'est
l'histoire de devoir des figures dans
des choses ou rien de faire apparaître
et j'ai un exemple dans le livre je vais
vous montrer où par exemple dans ce
livre il montre lors des attentats du 11
septembre
eh bien il ya eu énormément de films qui
ont été faits il ya énormément de gens
qui ont filmé et bien sûr les tours
pendant qu elle flambait et si on
regarde frime france image par image
toutes ces vidéos ont réussi très
facilement à en trouver certaines dans
lesquelles il ya des visages
il ya dix harkis apparaissent comme ici
ou encore une deuxième ici je vais
retirer le post-it même deuxième ici que
si on explore vraiment toutes les images
une par une
on va trouver des tas de trucs un peu
bizarres comme ça et que du coup
certains disent regardez c'est la preuve
qu'il ya quelque chose de machiavélique
dans ce qui s'est passé là dessus que le
diable en personne
venus visiter les tours lorsqu elle
flambait alors qu'en réalité quand on
connaît un peu le principe des parts et
dolly et la tendance de l'esprit humain
à vouloir revoir des visages des formes
partout c'est inévitable que dans des
milliards et des milliards d'image qui
ont été faites à l'époque il en est
quelques unes qui par chance nous donne
l'impression qu'il ya un visage là
dedans quoi d'accord c'est est ce que
c'est alors tu m'as tu m'as tu disais
que c'était un lit tout a découvert
assez tôt et avait 16 ans et sa 16 ans
et c'est ça c'était un livre à ce moment
là tu avais déjà à l'idée de parler de
science ou de faire des vidéos d'une
façon grandiose mais 16 ans tu penses
bien j'étais complètement paumé comme la
plupart des ados de 16 ans j'avais
aucune idée de ce que j'allais faire de
ma vie j'étais nul à l'école je savais
vraiment pas qu'est ce qui allait se
passer pour le futur donc ce livre d'une
manière il a été un peu une bouée de
sauvetage aussi pour moi pour pour
l'adolescent qui était un peu perdu à
l'époque très certainement hockey et le
diptyque question que l'on attend ou un
petit commentaire ou parce que
je n'entends pas elodie a passé les
tensions mathieu oui pardon est-ce que
tu l'as eu une seule fois ce bouquin à
l'époque où est-ce que tu l'a relu
depuis ouais alors je n'avais qu'à un
choix à l'époque mais je les relis
depuis plusieurs fois en fait et c'est
aussi une référence que quand je vois
parler d'un sujet dont je sais que le
livre traite aussi ça m'arrive souvent
de revenir sur le livre pour me rappeler
le livre qu'est ce qu'il disait à propos
de saba il disait ça donc c'est c'est
devenu pour moi une sorte de petit
bouquin de référence maintenant je sais
qu'il faut pas non plus le prendre trop
sérieusement parce que c'est pas c'est
pas non plus une sorte d'encyclopédie
lien c'est juste un livre d'esprit
critique bien foutu même moi j'ai une
fâcheuse tendance à l'utiliser comme si
c'était une encyclopédie pour quoi sans
doute parce que voilà il ya il ya comme
c'est un livre que j'ai lu dans mes
mains il ya de ça maintenant assez
longtemps un plus plus plus d'une
décennie plus de 15 ans il ya un
attachement émotionnel très fort à ce
lit d'ailleurs l'exemple âgées dans les
mains c'est l'original et ils commencent
à avoir vécu quoi là je sais pas si on
le voit mais on voit qu'il a été plaqué
la ville a mis à lui 1 1 il a il est à
dire je suis là déjà vécu quoi est ce
que tu veux nous parler d'un deuxième
livre avec lequel tu participes à ce
live
je crois que c'est sur un sujet tout à
fait différent alors sur un sujet tout à
fait différent le second livre dont j'ai
décidé de vous parler c'est un livre que
il n'est pas fait pour être embarqués en
vacances soyons très clairs là dessus il
n'est pas fait pour être embarqués en
vacances de par sa taille et son poids
alors je vais vous montrer les devant
moi je sais pas comment je vais m'en
tirer pour vous montrer il est assez
lourd parce que c'est un livre
d'infographie en fait c'est un recueil
de d'infographie qui sont pris
magnifiques les unes que les autres
je m'emmêle déjà les pinceaux pour le
soulever on essaye c'est vraiment ces
genres le livre tu peux l'utiliser pour
aplatir quoi que ce soit tu peux
l'utiliser pour repasser la chemise à la
rigueur trouve essayé et c'est un livre
que clairement on va pas mettre dans sa
valise ne va pas se mentir c'est
impossible de mettre dans sa valise
mais quand on lâche et soit le laisser
traîner sur sur la table du salon quand
il ya des invités qui viennent ça c'est
toujours du meilleur effet parce
qu'inévitablement il y en a un qui va
l'ouvrir et quand ils ouvrent il va le
voir tomber sur des trucs magnifique
alors on va quoi je vais essayer de vous
donner quelques exemples que j'ai
sélectionné c'est un livre contemplatif
et pas beaucoup de textes en général
c'est surtout pour contempler voici un
exemple
alors j'essaye de regarder ce que je
vous montre aussi c'est une carte de
quoi alors c'est une mégapole c'est une
très grande ville j'ai oublié le nom de
la ville et c'est pas très important
dont on à l'évolution spatio-temporelle
alors la première image le monde c'était
dans les années 75 en rouge vous avez
bas ce qu'était la ville où elle était
étendue là où s'était bâti et puis vous
avez en dessous genre une dizaine
d'années plus tard il ya vraiment eu une
explosion qu'elle sait vraiment est allé
jusqu'à 2010 ou en 2010 c'est devenu
vraiment une mégapole qui a tout envahi
on dirait presque un cancer qui c'est
qui s'est étalée sur tout le truc ça
c'est un exemple d'image qu'on a dans ce
genre de livre mais j'ai des trucs
encore plus sympa à vous montrer mais
ces pièces voilà ici il y en avait une
que moi je trouve vraiment magnifique
très très chouette l'image de manhattan
alors j'essaye de voir ce que je
voudrais on voit on voit ouais voilà que
vous voyez donc c'est manhattan convoi
et sur cette image de manhattan il ya
des points de couleur et si vous
regardez à trois couleurs et du rouge
il ya du bleu et du jaune et en fait ça
nous montre la localisation des
photographies qui ont été faites sur
smartphones selon que la personne est un
touriste un local où si on ne sait pas
alors rouge c'est les touristes bleus
c'est les locaux et jaune c'est on ne
sait pas et donc ce qu'on voit là dessus
c'est que les endroits kiss
ah ah attends tu as perdu nathan
trop de suspense alors là c'est trop dur
là nathan nathan revient là c'est pas
possible on tourne pas des pages de pub
dans les gouttes bucknor en est un on
est enfin temps réel il a peut-être un
petit soucis de connexion
un petit soucis de connexion ça t'arrive
parce que c'est la question que tu poses
et à nathan à l'instant ça arrive tu
dois d'avoir un bouquin même que tu as
lu il ya super longtemps et puis d'y
revenir de temps en temps pourri pour y
retrouver quelque chose de différent tu
avais pas lu la première fois alors il
ya des bouquins mais pas forcément des
bouquins de science mais il ya des
hommes des romans alors le bouquin que
j'ai dû lire le plein le plus grand
nombre de fois c'est tristan et iseult
mais en fait j'ai eu une obsession à un
moment dans ma jeunesse j'ai lu toutes
les versions parce qu'en fait c'est un
conte ses légendes celtiques fin c'est
une légende et il n'y a pas vraiment un
auteur qui a écrit un bouquin il ya
plusieurs versions de plein de choses et
donc du coup j'ai un peu lu toutes les
versions à l'époque je sais plus combien
de tristan les autres qui parfois parler
que de tristan ou que de machin etc
en ancien français enfin voilà avec un
ancien français voilà français pour
justement essayer de comprendre toute
l'histoire que je sois vraiment hyper
passionnante alors je crois que j'ai
envoyé un petit message pour lui dire
qu'on avait perdu le pourvoi est ce
qu'il est revenu il revient mais par
contre on a pas d'image malheureusement
on n'a pas d'image alors attendez je
vais essayer de régler ça donc ma
connexion internet a sauté je suis
désolé par contre tu entends tu peux au
moins finir ce que je te propose un
temps c'est de finir de ta phrase parce
qu'on était vraiment vraiment suspendus
à ses lèvres
et puis tu règles ton souci en te
reprend après si tu veux nous y faisons
ça alors dites moi qu'est ce que j'avais
10 ans dernier l'humanité en train de
nous montrer une image de manhattan avec
des couleurs qui représentait des
piétons qui représentait des voilà donc
on avait le rouge qui représentait les
touristes et le bleu
les locaux et donc c'est une image qui
était très impressionnant dans le sens
on voyait vraiment que les endroits où
elles et les touristes sont très
différentes des endroits où les locaux
font des photos et peut-être que c'est
le genre d'image qui serait intéressante
pour moi si un jour je vais à manhattan
décidé batailler dans les zones où les
locaux font le plus de photos il ya
peut-être des choses à voir là dedans
que les touristes rate complètement bon
nathan je te propose de te redonner la
parole pour finir au moins tout à
l'heure cette présentation ça un en tout
cas tu as dit beaucoup de choses
heureusement a été coupé plus tôt à
l'afrique au début ou fin
en tout cas c'est passionnant et je te
redonne la parole tout à l'heure nathan
et je te propose elodie s'est donné la
parole tout de suite à notre deuxième
invité si tu en es d'accord je suis tout
à fait d'accord on va recevoir mari très
vert de la boîte à curiosité notamment
posté une petite sa dernière vidéo ce
matin
ou alors si non ce qu'on peut faire ce
que marine sépare connecter si elle est
si elle est là excuse-moi les et là je
suis mauvaise langue mais qu'il salue
marie est ce que tu nous entends bonjour
marie bonjour oui je vous entends ça
commence avenue et bah ça va et vous ça
va on est au top pour autant qu'on
puisse enfin évidemment
alors tu es venu avec deux livres
également dans ce live absolument pas
déjà merci de m'avoir invité ça m'a fait
très plaisir
voilà merci le dis merci mathieu redire
pardon en fait je te coupe la parole
alors qu'après avoir posé la question
mais avant de parler de ces deux livres
tu peux peut-être juste représenter ce
que c'est que la boîte à curiosité oui
alors bien sûr avec plaisir donc je suis
mari de la boîte à curiosité qui est en
fait une chaîne youtube est aussi un
blog de sciences qui très axé biologie
et biologie insolite dans mes épisodes
je parle beaucoup d'espèces animales aux
moeurs étranges qui prêtent beaucoup pas
sourire ou
notamment je me déguise en ces animaux
je travaille autour du rire et de la
science et des animaux de la nature et
tu es également une lectrice de 12
ouvrages de sciences quels qu'ils soient
et est venue avec sous le bras deux de
ses livres tout à fait alors je suis
venu avec deux livres qui ont en fait un
point commun celui de la science
improbable on sait que ça me tient
beaucoup à coeur le premier livre c'est
aussi notre chance tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur le blog son
jab chercheuse au cnrs et elle nous
parle en fait de sa fabuleuse rencontre
avec le blob alors attends ça ça a coupé
tu peux juste redire redire de qui sais
pas si vous connaissez un petit peu le
blob alors vous m'entendez en tentant en
train de couper oms a été coupée tu peux
reprendre
oui donc je disais le blob d'audrey 10-q
turquie et chercheuse au cnrs et qui
nous parle de sa jolie rencontre avec
physarum police et pas l'homme donc le
blob est en fait c'est un petit livre
très accessible à chacun j'ai adoré le
langage qu'elle utilisait il faut savoir
que se livrent aussi a obtenu le prix
chances pour tous qui est délivrée par
les collégiens les lycéens et une fois
de plus cette taxe de délivrer de la
science pour tout le monde je trouve ça
juste génial il faut savoir qu elle nous
raconte cette histoire en nous
expliquant qu'en fait ce blog n'était
pas du tout prévu dans sa vie à la base
que c'est ça a été une rencontre un peu
un jour un collègue lui a ramené en lui
disant écoute faut que tu t'occupes de
ça mais qu'est ce que c'est c'est un
blog web on dirait une moisissure c'est
nul ça bouge pas ou 8 inquiète pas
occupants tués rails en fait elle parle
justement un peu de cet acte de cet
aspect sceptiques et pour qu'au final on
se dise 20 parfois quand on est
sceptique en fait le fait d'être
sceptique peut-être que c'est quelque
chose de bon au final c'est qu'il ya des
choses à découvrir derrière et est donc
en fait elle est tombé complètement
folle amoureuse de son blog elle a fait
des découvertes énorme à propos de ça et
elle nous parle donc de ce cette lettre
qui est unicellulaires qui peut avoir
des capacités d'apprentissage folle
trouver des sorties dans des labyrinthes
et c'est donc une fois de plus
ce nous invite vraiment elle le dit dans
le livre que s'intéresser une fois de
plus à des espèces qu'on ne connaît pas
ou qui peuvent nous paraître un peu
étrange pas forcément intéressante d'un
premier regard peuvent en fait tous
d'évolution des pleins de choses sur
sarko aujourd'hui le blob avec tout ce
qu'on sait maintenant à son propos on a
avant on commence à faire des liens
entre la recherche sur le cancer avec le
blog et avec le blog etc
donc voilà je fais ça super chouette de
cesser vraie invitation à la curiosité
toi quito qui connaît bien la question
de la curiosité avec la boîte à gants
quelle transition exceptionnel
magnifique matière non mais c'est vrai
c'est un truc qui un et l'auditoire
collégiens audrey dussutour tu la
connais oui allez allez elle est
passionnante et c'est vrai quand il
parle quand même barbe du blog c'est
c'est vraiment fou et déjà le blog c'est
un espèce de petit bonhomme farges du
petit bonhomme parce que bon on a envie
de dire comme un animal ce truc c'est
vrai mais non mais j'en voulais un
d'ailleurs mais c'est en fait
j'attendais je me dis à chaque fois je
voyage mais le confinement c j'aurais dû
en avoir un avant le confort et les
regarder
bah oui tu la mnef bleue visa il
s'appelle boby lapointe et donc pas dit
que c'était le moment idéal
effectivement le confinement pour tester
l'élevage et tu t'en occupes
régulièrement
ben ouais tu les genres et tous les
jours je fais des petites expériences on
peut les nourrir de manière différente
pour lui faire aller dans des directions
spécifiques etc
donc c'est vraiment juste facilement de
se dire ok au début moi c'est nul c'est
juste une moisissure et au final on sait
au bout de quelques jours on se rend
compte en fait de l'intelligence entre
guillemets que c'est peut-être peut
avoir et toutes les merveilles qui peut
nous offrir
si les travaux d'audrey dussutour vous
intéresse vous qui nous regarde et vous
qui regardez ce live en direct
n'hésitez pas à regarder la vidéo qu'on
a tourné avec audrey dussutour ça
s'appelle un jour avec audrey dussutour
la suite du matin au soir pour voir son
boulot et beaucoup de ce qu'a dit marie
se retrouve dans la vidéo quelqu'un de
passionné absolument de presque de
militants pour la pour la minorisation
scientifique également quelqu'un qui est
très consciente des enjeux que traverse
la recherche publique actuellement et
qui je crois dans le livre que je n'ai
pas lu mais je m'en a parlé dont je peux
en parler dans le livre elle
un mari elle rappelle aussi la nécessité
d'engager des des financements pour la
recherche fondamentale et de considérer
que la recherche se fait d'abord
peut-être par parle pas est-ce que je
vous m'entendez tout mais je pense que
c'est mathieu qu'on a perdu ouais c'est
ça ouais
est-ce que du coup je crois je vous
entends très bien c'est assez bon ton
super en fait il ya eu la fin de ta
phrase sur la recherche fondamentale qui
n'était pas intéressant ce défenseur
spécialement parce que là on parle de
livres de vacances mais c'est vrai que
la recherche fondamentale c'est un truc
c'est juste trente secondes que je vais
dire mais en fait on se dit toujours oui
on ne sait pas c'est pas intéressant
c'est des trucs vraiment qu'ils servent
à rien bah ouais mais sauf qu'on sait
pas dans 10 ou 20 ans est-ce que ça va
se faire faire ou pas et il ya beaucoup
de recherche appliquée qui au final se
base sur de la recherche fondamentale
d'il ya quelques années donc ça et j'ai
trouvé ça super chouette de sa part en
fait de jouer la carte de la franchise
surtout dans un livre comme ça en fait
quand on feuillette les premières pages
on se dit bon ça va être un guide du
globe et c est en fait pas du tout et
non seulement elle arrive à garder cet
aspect sympathique mais aussi voilà de
jouets cartes franchir la recherche
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué ça
soulève enfin sa demande de soulever
beaucoup moyens qu'ils soient financiers
ou autres c'est le chercheur donne sa
vie à son métier et ses contraintes là
elle elle en parle c'est super
intéressant d'avoir publié les deux en
fait de se dire ok ce blog n'était pas
prévu dans ma vie et cette recherche l'a
va peut-être nous mener à des
découvertes incroyables et bat pour que
je puisse continuer à travailler il faut
soulever des moyens et voilà de lier
tout ça c'est super intéressant
super on vous met le lien vers la vidéo
de grands labos dans le chat un jour
avec audrey dussutour vous mais
également le lien vers le livre
dont on vient de parler marie a donc
tout ce que vous avez toujours voulu
savoir sur le blog sans jamais avoir osé
le demander je crois que ça tombe d'un
genre j'aime pas l'intégrale du titre
sous les yeux et tu es venu avec un un
deuxième livre marie s'était fait d'un
un grand passeur de science ouais alors
ça c'est un livre de pierre barthélémy
qui est donc chroniqueur pour le monde
c'est un livre qui s'appelle donc
chronique de sciences improbable date
pas d'hier et là 2013 quand même mais
juste pour moi il est génial c'est
justement ce genre de bouquin qui
suscite d étincelle de curiosité et qui
donne envie d'en savoir plus
donc c'est une compilation en fait d'un
article qu'il a publié dans le
supplément du monde science et techno et
dans lequel en fait il nous propose de
voir la science improbables comme une
façon comique d'interroger la méthode
scientifique est en fait le livre est
organisé c'est juste deux trois pages
par petits fais insolites et donc en
fait c'est plein de questions
complètement loufoque mais qui
finalement bas comme pareil comme audrey
dussutour même temps fait elle est
découverte vraiment intéressante qui
peut faire avancer la science
ça va du ce que bon très bien on sait
que les humains on le fait de bayer est
contagieux mais est ce que ça fonctionne
aussi sur les portes eu donc il ya des
chercheurs qui ont fait des demandes et
des recherches très poussées sur est ce
que les tortues on a un bâillement
contagieux entre elles pourquoi la
tartine tout tombe toujours du côté
beurré pourquoi et c est en fait c'est
super c'est toujours ça c'est comment
cette science qui au début on se dit
mais on s'en fiche en fait de savoir
pourquoi la tartine tombe mais en fait
non puisque ça va nous mener à des
choses super intéressantes et il ya
aussi des anecdotes qui parle de
justement ces chercheurs qui parfois
vous très très loin dans
l'investissement qu'il donne il ya un
chercheur gourmand dans le mille neuf
cent 2 qui a voulu démontrer que la
pendaison était un moyen de peine de
mort très
très désagréable et qui du coup a passé
des mois à s'auto pendre petit à petit
chez lui pour prouver faire des échelles
de douleurs de pendaisons et prouver qu
en fait oui la peine de mort par
pendaison était absolument abominable
donc il ya vraiment beaucoup d'anecdotes
qui au début nous font esquissé des
sourires mais soulève une fois plus des
questions très importantes
je le crois je crois que pire c'est pas
mal inspiré des ignobel 1 elodie ça
c'est quelques chalets amende et ça en
fait ça me fait penser exactement ça je
crois qu'il ya eu alors en fait ils
gênent nobel non enfin ignobel en fait
en anglais c'est ignoble ignoble
voilà c'est juste parce que nous on dit
souvent il gêne aux belles et du coup ça
fait pas grève est assez rigolo mais
effectivement il y en a il ya eu une
telle recherche moi qui m'a marqué en
biologie humaine ou en médecine il ya
quelques passes c'était là où il ya
qu'il ya quelques mois sur le fait de
mettre des gens qui avaient des caillots
reno dans des dents des grands 8 pour
moi si ça les regarde et allait
dissoudre plus facilement ou pas en fait
pas loin mon dieu ça et là il faut se
dire qu'il ya de la vraie science 1
elodie faut le dire ou de la vraie sied
en fait c'est ça c'est de la vraie
science etc des vraies questions
derrière et on fait parfois il ya des
trucs qui paraissent complètement
saugrenue et en fait quand on lit les
papiers on se dit ah non mais c'est
intéressant
c'est juste que si on sort le truc comme
ça c'est vrai que ça paraît complètement
dingos mais sa part de l'idée de se dire
bah oui un caillou
un caillou durée par exemple c'est en
place est ce que si on secoue la
personne à fond est-ce que ça va pas
aider faire passer le truc alors voilà
et c'est vrai c'est une bonne idée c'est
une bonne question est bien sûr et c'est
assez fantastique parce que c'est vrai
que souvent on a toujours des idées de
la science comme des trucs hyper carré
hyper fin des protocoles toujours bien
bien défini c'est drôle de voir que
parfois c'est farfelu et que ces trucs
farfelu ça amène justement à des grandes
découvertes ou à des trucs hyper
important quoi le nom de films arrivent
asie non en fait je rebondis juste sur
ce que disait elodie dans le dans le
même style de ses calculs rénaux il ya
vous regarder absolument ils ont alors
une étude sur et un brevet de déposer
par deux chercheurs sur la table
d'accouchement rotatives
c'est en fait un espèce de plateau sur
laquelle on allonge les femmes enceintes
avec un sac moi mais eux pour voilà ils
ont essayé de trouver comment en fait on
pouvait faire un coup chez les femmes
avec le moins de douleur possible par la
force centrifuge donc ils ont vraiment
créé des plans etc et conçu une table
d'accouchement c'est un espace de
plateau qui tourne je crois que c'est 80
tours par minute pour éjecter en fait le
bébé plus rapidement et que ça soit
moins toujours eu mais également des
trucs amour et de là mais il faut savoir
que c'est quand même absolument sérieux
puisque la la série des nobel se déroule
pm dans la harvard donc c'est quand même
pas quelque chose de oui c'est ça ça te
fait léger quoi c'est vraiment très très
sérieux ouais c'est pas sérieux mais
vrai ça part et ça paraît complètement
loufoque au départ quoi mais là ils vont
fort marri médard c'est mille fois
d'avoir été avec nous dans ce bateau-là
y goûte beau merci on a une prochaine
vidéo a annoncé éventuellement sur la
boîte à gants au regard des abers sorti
ce matin je m'adonne confinement tout à
fait et voilà
est ce que je fais bien de poser la
question et aller potasse tic
merci et le dis franchement merci eh
bien écoutez c'est un livre est un vrai
bonheur de t'avoir avec nous merci pour
cette 2 super recommandations et puis
très bonne continuation et très bonne
route à toi / dans le youtube game
mattia merci elodie jaïbi voilà elodie
alors tu vas bien ouais je fais bien ça
va j'ai mon j'ai bientôt fini montée
mais c'est pas grave j'ai pas commencé
mon verre d'eau on va continuer à n'ont
fait enfin qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait là écoute moi ce que je propose
c'est à moi qu'on attend on va essayer
de demander à en attendre revenir de 2
secondes pour dire au moins la fin de sa
sélection et puis la tenture soit on te
voit
oui je vous reçois yes donc juste je
m'en serais je m'en sens révolue et le
dis moi que tu es pas pu terminer ta
petite présentation du de ceux de ce
livre une formation graphics de cendrars
engen qui est en train de montrer des
cartes et voilà si tu veux juste nous
nous de finir de nous présenter ce cet
ouvrage mais je vais vous montrer une
dernière carte de cet ouvrage une
dernière carte de cet ouvrage que moi
j'aime bien je vais essayer de vous
montrer à nouveau ce pas facile parce
qu'il est très lourd donc ce que l'on
voit
alors ce qui est drôle c'est que je dois
essayer de voir est ce que vous voyez ce
que je vous montre
on dirait que oui voyez il ya une ligne
une ligne diagonale blanche et le long
de cette ligne diagonale blanche
on a plusieurs époques dans le temps
alors on a d'abord tout en bas à gauche
on a les années 1800 et ce qui se passe
c'est con à différents cercles dont le
rayon de chaque cercle représente le
revenu médian dans différents pays
donc on a différentes couleurs une pour
chaque nuit et ce qu'on voit qui est
très intéressant c'est que dans les
années 1800 le revenu médian il était
assez faible les cercles sont de
rejoindre et il était plus ou moins le
même pour tous les pays du monde en fait
tout en tout cas pour tous les pays
représentés sur cette infographie et à
mesure qu'on voyage dans le temps et
qu'on se rapproche de notre époque on
voit qu'il ya vraiment une explosion des
revenus médians on voit qu'il ya
vraiment une explosion des cercles en
fête ou sas a grandi très très vite
on voit aussi ça s'accompagne d'une
énorme disparité à l'échelle de la
planète où pendant très longtemps il ya
des cercles qui sont restés petit donc
des pays qui ont stagné stagné en la
matière et des cercles ont grandi
extrêmement vite et le cercle plus
extérieur par exemple qu'on voit à
chaque fois c'est les états unis et puis
les 2e siècle
les plus extérieur ces genres
l'allemagne ou le japon
donc ça c'est un exemple de
représentation de l'évolution des
revenus médians dans le temps que je
trouve excessivement réussi qui est
vraiment magnifique qui permettent de
bien visualiser la chose et est du coup
c'est le l'auteur de ce livre donc
auteur re cendrars nguen tu peux nous en
dire un petit mot qu est ce que tu sais
d'elle alors je ne sais strictement rien
d'elle je vais pas mentir je ne sais
strictement rien d'elle puisque moi j'ai
une fâcheuse tendance que ce soit dans
les livres ou dans les films
même si j'adore le film où le livre je
ne renseignent pas sur les acteurs ni
sur le directeur ni quoi que ce soit
d'autre et donc la plupart du temps j'ai
aucune idée de qui sont exactement les
gens qui sont derrière vous que c'est
rien dire enfin un deuxième good book
saver spécial auteurs qui sont ils
vraiment mais ça peut être un sujet
intéressant de nous parfois on a
l'impression que c'est on se fait des
représentations sur les hauteurs femmes
ou hommes de ces livres qui sont pas
toujours très juste
en tout cas merci beaucoup nathan avec
d'avoir pris le temps de de participer à
ce live pour nous parler de ses deux
beaux livres donc je rappelle le premier
c'était devenez sorcier devenait savant
de georges charpak et enseignants
proches voilà et une formation que la
fixe de cendrars nguen c'est vraiment de
livres c'est bien parce que c'est très
différent et un temps très
complémentaires et on sent bien qu'on
approche sceptiques et on approche en de
la prendre de la distance par rapport
aux informations et prendre les choses
dans leur dans leur globalité
un petit peu ce que je retiens en tout
cas de livres de son bar nguen ça donne
vraiment il est il a l'air vraiment
super intéressant en fait tu peux passer
des heures de donc oui et ça doit coûter
cher aussi peut-être oui alors moi on me
l'a offert donc j'ai de la chance merci
non pas de ma grand mère non en fait il
ya plus récent celui là même est à mon
avis ils coûtent plus d'une centaine
d'euros je pense 1
et universitaires ou autre merci
beaucoup n'attendent avoir été d'avoir
été des nôtres
est ce qu'on peut annoncer peut-être un
truc concernant chat sceptique dans une
vidéo sur laquelle tu bosses ou quelque
chose que tu as sur lequel tu as
travaillé mardi prochain au soir mardi
14 avril à 21h je vais tenter le premier
life statistiques de la chaîne où je
vais apprendre aux jeunes à lire
quelques statistiques sur ordinateur
donc voilà sfr qui en a qui veulent
apprendre à faire les bases de la
statistique sur logiciel c'est mardi
soir à 21h sur la chaîne du shass
éthique mardi soir 21h chaîne us hâtive
du chat sceptique tout ce que vous avez
toujours voulu savoir sur les stats sans
jamais et les logiciels de stats sans
jamais oser le demander merci beaucoup
d'attentes très bonne fin d'après-midi à
toi et puis il ya une prochaine ciao
voilà je suis content elodie qu'on ait
pu avoir la fin de la présentation m
c'est bien c'est bien et ce bouquin
aller il est vraiment il a l'air hyper
intéressant bouquin traduits en plus ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas on a
parfois de d'excellents livres à
transition sa vie ça on a parfois
d'excellents livres publiés en
angleterre en allemagne publié dans
d'autres coins du monde aux états unis
qui n'arrive pas en france ils sont pas
traduits et pourquoi
parmi les appétences des publics parce
qu'il faut trouver les bonnes personnes
pour les traduire parce que quoi alors
fait alors le truc que j'ai pas dit tout
à l'heure sur toi t bills règles il faut
le dire mais moi je suis bilingue à peu
près enfin 8 bilingue oui si si je suis
bilingue je suis bien que je garde mon
nom en fait j'ai toujours à peu près
parce que je garde mon un peu mon accent
français mais mais effectivement je suis
bilingue et non je vais demander le truc
que j'ai oublié de dire autour des bars
et que je suis en train d'écrire un
bouquin de sciences sur le cerveau chez
dunod de la collection vite fait on opte
de la collection 50 grandes idées on se
lève c'est sur la science mais du coup
moi et mon co auteur ce sera sur le
cerveau et du coup j'ai demandé j'ai
demandé à quelqu'un chez dunod en fait
pourquoi il n'y a pas plus de livres
traduits moi ce que je me disais c'est
que peut-être que si on demande aux gens
de traduire des livres parce qu'il faut
généralement
jean par exemple des bouquins sur le
cerveau il faut des gens qui est un
petit peu de connaissances en euros pour
le faire je me disais peut-être que
quitte à traduire un livre autant
l'écrire soi même et c est en fait il ya
une raison qui est hyper intéressante
aussi c'est que si il s'était beaucoup
plus il n'ya qu'un nombre de bouquins x
qui peuvent publier par an et du coup
dans la ligne éditoriale mais si jamais
ils traduisent trop de bouquins ça veut
dire qu'il n'ya pas de création
française qui sera mise en avant et du
coup il préfère mettre en avant la
création française et du coup la
création tout court aussi parce qu'au
final si jamais il ya une maison
d'édition qui traduit énormément de
bouquins mais qui n'a pas d'auteur
originaux et qui n'est enfin qu'ils
n'écrivent pas pour eux mais au final
c'est plus de la création et c'est pas
de la création française non plus c'est
juste de la traduction de la création
d'un autre pays donc voila quand j'ai
demandé chez dunod ils m'ont dit ça on
aimerait bien on en a un certain
pourcentage suivant les années je crois
que ça voilà c'est peut-être autour de
30 ou ça dépend des éditeurs ça dépend
des sujets bien sûr donc ça rentre dans
la line d'édition mais du coup ils
veulent les séries de la place à la
création française ce qui est hyper
noble et ça se comprend tout à fait donc
c'est vrai que parfois il ya des
bouquins on veut dire ça serait chouette
qu'ils soient traduits mais bon c'est
aussi mieux d'avoir des bouquins
d'auteur français et lui donc nous a
parlé là
un peu en avant première le livre sur le
cerveau c'est un peu compliqué parce
qu'avec tout ce qui se passe j'imagine
que tant qu elle va pas être tellement
disponibles - non non alors
effectivement mon co auteur c'est un
psychiatre qui travaillent sur
l'addiction à l'alcool est là en ce
moment on m'a clairement fait au tout
début de la crise on a dit à l'éditrice
là ça va juste être pas possible parce
que lui en hôpital déjà c'était
compliqué mais là en terme de gérer tout
ça c'était c'est pas possible donc pour
l'instant moi je vois là j'essaie
d'avancer avec le reste de cerveau qui
me reste en confinement
mais voilà c'est ça va être ça serait
plutôt dû 2021 quaprès je pense je pense
qu'on n'a pas dates précises parce que
c'est vrai qu'avec avec tout ça on est
un peu on a un peu mis en pause mais
voilà bon bah écoute on suivra avec
beaucoup d'intérêt et puis bah du coup
je te propose qu'on passe au un autre
invité suivant pour là encore parler de
choses encore très différent vous allez
voir on va voyager avec lui il s'agit de
la dalle et nguyen hoang alias ans fort
nous rejoint tranquillement dans ce live
si vous assistez si vous suivez ce live
en direct n'hésitez pas bien sûr à
partager salut l'est vos commentaires
vos réactions à poser vos questions à
partager vos livres vos coups de coeur
de bande dessinée dessus de deux romans
de science-fiction décès de monographies
c'est vraiment important de pouvoir
faire des suggestions
c'est nous ça nous intéresse en plus
bonjour les comment tu vas à la trappe
comment se passe ton confinement
d'autres je suis très occupé pendant le
confinement est pas j'essaie de tenir
très informés en fait surtout des ce qui
se passe en ce moment pour voir si je
peux aider autant que en apportant des
explications de certains certain concept
dans il ya en ce moment il ya pas mal
d'applications qui sont en train de
développer pour être à la fois précis
mais faire aussi du contact récit ça
fait beaucoup de lecture ouais et tu
arrives à te dire que tu tues tu écris
aussi je crois en ce moment tu prépares
un livre alors non pour il est fini dans
lequel arrivent qui va sortie donc j'ai
un livre est un livre qui devrait sortir
avant l'été
il ya des preuves de la maison d'édition
à cause du confinement aussi à pas très
sûrs d'eux quand est-ce que ça sortir
exactement mais ce qui est prévu pour
mai à la base
adacore donc c'est un livre qui
s'appelle tuerie mais à la plage je l'aï
déjà écrit
bon d'accord donc ça c'est fait ça c'est
fait il ya plus qu'à le lire mais ça va
ça va bien tomber cela dit si c'est
turing à la plage dès qu'il arrive ce
dans les bacs en juillet cet homme là
c'est l'objectif
après est ce qu'on sera à la plage en
juillet on va espérer passer chez dunod
du coup même même maison moi c'est vrai
et on avoue que ce livre que tu écris
que tu as écrit qui va sortir bientôt
on s'appelle turing à la plage
l'intelligence artificielle dans un
transat
donc l'idée du livre c'est vraiment de
d'expliquer ce qui est noté jean
certifie ciel mais avec un gros accent
sur la proche de turing parce qu'en fait
tu as écris un article en 1950 qui est
vraiment vraiment fabuleux concerne un
article et un truc déjà une machine
learning effectivement fait machine
learning a été inventé avant
l'intelligence artificielle et est en
fait c'est un livre qui qui qui vaut 20
articles qui est vraiment fabuleux et
qu'on décortique un petit peu mais aussi
à la lumière des les avancées récentes
d'accord ben écoute on suivra ton fils
twitter est un j'imagine tu vois une
petite annonce aussi dans sur sa chaîne
youtube science for all quand lille sera
sortir imagine ouais bon on regardera ça
avec grand intérêt était venu avec deux
livres à toi dans ce lot spécial good
book ce que j'adore utilise à plein pour
ce qu'il a lu en version numérique mais
c'est pas grave mais on y croit j'ai
ouais j'ai quand même la couverture du
premier
je vais parler donc sa belle être bien
dans sa peau alors techniquement en fait
je les joue seulement en fait il s était
en anglais non plus je n'ai pas lu je
les écoutais radio est restée un livre
grimpait trichet sur circuit mais c'est
un livre qui est très très très agréable
en tout cas à écouter jean également à
lire
c'est un livre qui apparemment est
thérapeutique il ya des études qui ont
été faites pour apprécier de devoir les
de l'impact ce livre pour des personnes
par exemple qui sont en dépression et et
donc il ya des études en essai contrôlé
randomisé qui ont montré que cet effet
ce que ce livre avait un effet
thérapeutique
donc c'est si jamais vous vous sentez
pas très bien pendant confinant au
hasard voilà je recommande vivement de
décider au t1 ailleurs et ce livre voilà
si vous avez du mal à vous procurer une
version physique vous pouvez l'acheter
une aération électronique voire avoir
écouté le livre audio
ça parle de quoi c'est un livre qui
décrit ce qu'on appelle à la thérapie
comportementale la thérapie cognitive
comportementale qui en rose et un
ensemble de techniques comportementales
pour essayer de se sentir mieux et c'est
plein de petits conseils qui apparemment
ont été efficaces et cultive haute et
très étudié visiblement sont efficaces
donc il ya pas mal de petits conseils à
à tenir
gardez en tête que l'un des conseils par
exemple c'est vous êtes vraiment frustré
par quelque chose sur sa page à mais
j'aimerais être en fait ce qu'est ce que
ce que propose donc l'auteur david byrne
s'est décrit hier sur un bout de papier
votre sentiment
mais en fait ça c'est très utile parce
que ça externalise votre sentiment du
coup ça me permet de le figer et de ne
pas avoir ce truc qui tourne toujours
dans votre tête
c'est un truc que je fais de temps en
temps que je ne voulais pas faire si
souvent que ça mais c'est un truc qui me
paraît vraiment vraiment utile que ça
soulage un petit peu c'est plein en fait
ce livre là ses bases c'est plein de
conseils pratiques qui peuvent
voilà qui qui aide les gens quotidien
mais j'imagine que c'est bien sûr basé
sur de la science s'est basé sur des
études comportementales sur des des
analyses plus théorique plus globale
quel substrat de théorique de cet
ouvrage pas donc c'est un peu une
combinaison de tout ça donc il ya un peu
des raisonnements théorique derrière il
ya des essais cliniques qui ont été
faits aussi à côté de ça et moi ce que
je trouve intéressant c'est que ce livre
s'arrête pas juste à au bien-être mental
qui fait qu'ils aient déjà et je pense
est extrêmement important c'est sympa
une problématique que je me pose un peu
souvent c'est comment par exemple faire
du bien pour l'humanité quelles
questions une meilleure façon de faire
du bien pour l'humanité
tu vois on pourrait se dire que si les
gens ont accès à plus de bien basse et
rendra plus heureux mais ça c'est pas si
clair que ça soit vrai ça dépend de
bouffon les biens de base dit oui mais à
avoir une nouvelle belle console une
belle voiture c'est parce pas clair que
sa route tant au bonheur
et peut-être qu'aujourd'hui la
principale limite au bonheur au spa lé
frontières ce serait plus de d'apprendre
à mieux gérer ses propres émotions et à
développer soi-même des techniques pour
être plus à l'aise plus plus tranquille
plus heureux plus épanouie et en tout
cas ce parce qu'il ya aussi un peu cette
idée que lorsque enfin ya un espèce de
jeu à somme nulle sur le sur le bonheur
si on fait des efforts peut-être que au
final en moyenne c'est vrai qu'on va
finir par par pas être plus heureux que
ça ce livre suggère que c'est pas du
tout le cas en fait on peut vraiment
travailler ça c'est vraiment un exercice
à faire au jour le jour pour essayer de
progresser et avoir un bonheur plus
c'est un peu bizarre d'émerger devant
mais un bonheur plus robuste j'allais
dire ça pique ça mais c'était très
robuste est en ce moment en toi voilà
plein d'attentions de robustesse est
chez elle à ces critiques la
neuroscientifique en moi ils décrivent
un peu certains mécanismes du coup
comment ça que commença talent alors il
ya une partie à la fin qui est plus haut
niveau biochimiques d'accord mais
j'avoue que c'est la partie que j'ai
fait ou du moins à comprendre c'est
aussi le moins appliqués pour quelqu'un
qui parce que c'est plus du coup bah
c'est ce prêt prescrit par un psychiatre
d'accord je peux pas me la piquer moi
j'étais plus intéressé par les autres
partis de vivre mais peut-être que c'est
parti très non mais c'est intéressant de
voir justement qui a tout parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de bouquins qui sont au final
un peu c'est un peu du n'importe quoi
oui disent ah tu vas il donne les grands
principes de genre ah tu te sentiras
mieux si tu fais ça
mais au final c'est pas vraiment du
sérieux et derrière il n'y a pas de
vraiment de voilà de preuves ou de
mécanismes un petit peu donc là là tu
viens de me vendre jet voilà je suis
content il se passe un truc ça serait
chouette si on pouvait passer le bouquin
physiquement mais en tout cas ça existe
en ligne il ya un deuxième livre avec
lequel tu es venu dans ce live
une fois c'était pas physiquement mais
oui j'ai un autre livre qui est un livre
ii du chancelier du sénat conservateur
et grand officier de la légion d'honneur
il a plein de titres dior sa couverture
si on voit très bien donc c'est un livre
du marquis du compte la place pierre
simon laplace
je sais que c'est un vieux livre qui
date de 2014 a écrit par par la place
donc ceux qui me connaissent un peu
savent que je suis il ya un grand fan de
la place et en particulier de ce livre
de la place que j'ai lu finalement assez
récemment quelques mois tu peux juste
pour pitcher qui est la place pour
celles et ceux qui sont par exemple pas
du tout atlanta discipline donc la place
les très connus souvent pour son travail
plus en astronomie dont qui a fait
beaucoup de choses en astronomie est
également en mathématiques donc il ya
des théorèmes des mathématiques des
objets mathématiques de la place il est
bizarrement peut-être un peu moins connu
pour son travail en probabilité alors
que je pense que son travail en
probabilité est vraiment bluffante à la
nation m ces séances en oeuvre et en
particulier donc avant lui avec de
gentils on a essayé de faire des
probabilités et qui ne s'était plus des
probabilités déductive c'est à dire des
bas si je sais que une pièce a une
chance sur deux de tomber sur piles
quelle est la probabilité que si la
lance mille fois sa phase 6 ans pile
c'est ça c'est des coûts des produits
étaient un peu déductive on sait la
source du hasard on regarde les
conséquences le génie de la place et
d'avoir introduit un autre type de
progrès qui sont des prêts des
probabilités inductive c'est plus voilà
j'observe des choses est ce que
quelqu'un quelles sont les lois du
hasard qui sont derrière ce que
j'observe notamment il a écrit un
mémoire en 1776 qui s'appelle mémoire
sur la probabilité des causes à partir
des événements et le raisonnement c'est
que on observe toujours les événements
n'observe pas les causes et lille et de
la place c'est de dire on peut faire ce
travail de romain péault cause et pour
cela il propose d'utiliser les
probabilités et dans cet essai sur une
note dans cet essai philosophique sur
des probabilités
c'est quoi c'est un ouvrage où un texte
qu'il écrit à la fin et qui résume un
peu toutes ces idées ou c'est au
contraire un texte fondateur qui est la
graine de laquelle va naître la plante
des statistiques
la version 1 2 des probabilités version
la place cette phrase est trop longue à
ccc travers d'autres cas c'est la très
bonne question puisque en fait ce livre
c'est vraiment le livre à la fin de la
vie de leurs vers la fin de la vidéo la
place donc j'essaie et cité son mémoire
de 1776 ça c'est à 2814 donc c'est parce
que 40 ans plus tard et donc c'est en
fin de carrière où il fait sans que son
bilan et c'est un livre qui est pas
mathématique qui est très peu
mathématiques parce qu'en fait ils vont
pas les mathématiques les a faites avant
les essais sont été développé sa marque
mais la question qui se pose dans sedan
se danse dans cet ouvrage c'est plus la
question philosophique de qu'est-ce
qu'une probabilité est le truc très
traître qui peut être très perturbant et
qui rend ce livre vraiment vraiment
génial c'est que très très tôt en fait
qui va combattre le le probabiliste de
l'univers et iv il va il va défendre ce
qu'on appelle le déterminisme la place
tien c'est à dire l'idée que si les lois
de l'univers
fondée à l'époque où on pensait que
c'était la loi de newton
si elles sont telles qu'elles sont et si
on connaît l'état de l'univers alors on
peut déduire tout son futur il n'y a
plus rien d'un certain fait pas recette
est très pensé à lightning c'est ça
ouais c est qu est ce qu on appelle le
démon de la place aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment c'est ce déterminisme du monde
et du coup ça peut pas très bizarre que
dans un livre où il va défendre les
probabilités ils l'ouvrent en disant non
non il n'y a pas de profiter dans le
monde dis moi là est ce que cet ouvrage
là tu le trouve difficilement en version
numérique
il faut chercher un peu sur internet
pour le lire ou est ce que c'est un
livre qui s'est dit régulièrement j'ai
folio gallimard ou chez livre de poche
ou alors j'ai pas de j'ai pas lu sa
version papier donc je ne sais pas trop
si en fait je sais pas s'il ya des rires
sur papier mais il est accessible
gratuitement sur internet
ce qu'il cherchait et séchez les office
web et ben on va en mettre à ça dans le
dans le dans le chatt essai
philosophique tout le génie de ce livre
c'est que du coup il va considérer que
les probabilités
en fait c'est notre ignorance je vais
faire une égalité définitionnelle qu'il
va dire je vais appeler une certaine
hier probabilité ce qui est notre
ignorance ou ignorant ceux qui vont trop
probabilité est donc et ça c'est
vraiment un saut conceptuel qui est
absolument énorme et qui aura été rejeté
pendant plus d'un siècle moque et
souvent même pendant et encore
aujourd'hui beaucoup de vent beaucoup
mal avec cette idée mais c'est encore un
débat mais bon moi j'ai complètement
sauté du camp de réalité dans le camp de
la place à vrai dire je trouve que les
probabilités c'est un outil fabuleux
pour décrire notre ignorance
bon écoute super merci pour cette course
est insight sur un univers qu'on
maîtrise pas très bien en tout cas moi
personnellement je ne maîtrise pas du
tout mais par contre je quand je tente
quand je t'entends en parler j'ai
l'impression que ça me ça me le rendre
familier donc merci beaucoup
d'une part pour cette sélection de
livres et puis je parle sous le contrôle
des lots dit pour tout le travail que tu
fais dans une mobilisation via science
for all et puis tu es tu es très présent
tout sous des formes différentes et moi
personnellement c'est ce que j'appelle
ce jeu c'est ce que j'apprécie beaucoup
chez toi c'est que tu essayes des choses
différentes et les livres les
conférences les podcasts les lives on
est content de t'avoir sur cette chaîne
youtube
ouais mais bercy veut plus donc très
belle continuation à toi et puis et puis
a très vite
à bientôt et elodie je te propose de mai
c'était passionnant et franchement l'asm
moyenne nationale
ouais moi aussi alors que pour le coup
je pense que les probabilités c'est un
des trucs sur lequel mon cerveau bug
vraiment bug pourtant je vois les allées
moi je faisais de la génétique donc je
devais le faire et en fait je me
retrouvais à chaque fois je j'arrive pas
à quoi je sais il ya non conservé dit
non je suis sûre il a des bras c'était
il a les bras croisés comme ça à
l'intérieur de mon crâne effet non non
je veux pas c'est pour ça que là il
arrive vraiment la paix il a le courage
dirait de de vouloir faire de la
vulgarisation sur des sujets qui sont
quand même pas facile du tout quoi c'est
plus simple de base le croire de parler
d'histoire par exemple que de parler de
probabilités me semble-t-il ne serait-ce
que parler parce que l'histoire par
définition c'est un récit et tu peux tu
peux te greffer dessus des probabilités
c'est plus compliqué de créer enfin je
pense en tant que tel qui arrive à les y
arrive toujours bien et c'est vrai que
c'est un de ses superpouvoirs c'est que
surtout comme tu disais tout à l'heure
sur plus en plus on en profite
maintenant il est plus là on peut dire
plein de trucs bien sûr lui soit qu'il
soit gêné dans mais c'est vrai que il
fait sur différents formats il arrive à
embarquer sur sur les probas qui est pas
un sujet super facile mais c'est vrai
que quand on écoute les on se sent
vachement plus confiance à ce probant ça
c'est le très cool on a besoin de lui
merci pour tout allez on a besoin de
quelqu'un d'autre se laisse le pèle de
ouais c'est qui alors c'est clotilde de
chamoux si oui assez sauvage à entend
bien ça lui que le silk way salut
attendez je coupe youtube parce que je
sais bon tu doives un petit à petit ses
anciennes timing autre émission ou série
commence à voir clotilde très bien ça va
merci pour l'invitation merci pour voir
si territoriale paillot c'est chouette
mais en fait c'est ce que je disais tout
à son salut voila je défais avant avant
que tu es valider sa participation donc
tu vois je me suis dit bout ça va c'est
pas parce que tu étais invité mais c'est
merci tu nous représente en un mot pas
ces sauvages beaucoup de gens
connaissent mais bon on représente assez
une chaîne accès chair humaine et
sociale qui
voilà qui vulgarise l'archéologie et
l'anthropologie et l'histoire et j'ai
pas mal traité de la préhistoire
ce soit sur la chaîne mais aussi sur le
bord text voilà est donc le premier
livre que je voulais vous présenter qui
est vraiment vraiment un coup de coeur
et ça a beaucoup beaucoup influencé la
chaîne et ses partis pris c'est un livre
d'alain testard qui est un anthropologue
qui est mort en 2013 et donc à la fin de
sa vie il a écrit ce livre qui s'appelle
la ds et le grain donc ça sent un peu
enfin il ya une sorte de précipitation
dans l'écriture mais c'est ce qui le
rend encore plus touchant c'est un livre
qui propose des interprétations des
religions néolithique ou plutôt qui qui
vient contrer certaines fausses idées
notamment celui laissé qui m'a le plus
interpellé c'est celui sur un présupposé
enfin le mil delà de la déesse mère du
matriarcat qui vient donc d monter très
rapidement et ce avec des exemples
contemporains en prenant notre notre
société actuelle qui dresse un pont
entre eux ouais on évoque complet séparé
de plusieurs siècles
voilà et il en montre pas toutes les
citer toutes les similarités et c'est
frappant parce qu'il travaille sur sur
l'image et sur la production
c'est-à-dire il ya une dimension
économique qui produit les images pour
qui est donc le fil rouge si vous voulez
de de ce livre c'est est-ce que la
prolifération des images et notamment la
des images de femmes
donc il prend les statuettes statuette
néolithique on connaît bien avec des
formes très opulente
est-ce que leur prolifération parce
qu'on retrouve partout sur tous les cas
sur toute l'europe tout le proche orient
est ce que c'est un indice d'une
situation privilégiée et il répond très
rapidement non non et pourquoi parce que
toutes époques confondues ce sont les
hommes qui manipulent c'est à dire qu'il
qui commande les images de
et particulièrement être aussi et
particulièrement les images de femmes
nues et ça on le voit très bien de nos
jours pour vendre un dentifrice ou une
voiture mais souvent une femme dénudée
et c'est absolument pas la traduction
d'une émancipation mais c'est plutôt un
argument très fort d'une d'un patriarcat
exacerbée et c'est très intéressant
parce que les mythes de la mère nature
de la déesse mère du matriarcat c'est
est ce que tu peux nous en parler en
quelques tout petits mots parce que
toutes celles et ceux qui nous regardent
sont pas forcément aussi bon connaisseur
que toi de ces sujets par exemple le
mythe de la ds mais en un mot alors bas
on va reprendre ses statuettes statuette
que peut-être beaucoup d'entre nous
avons vu ce sont des petites statuettes
en argile qui on voit là une fabrication
qui a c'est pas très élaboré oui mais
voilà c'est ça alors ça mais voilà
c'était juste pour dire que dans retour
vers le palais au du coup il ya un
chapitre qui voit là des statuts alors
ces statuettes basson voilà sont faites
dans l'argile à sont façonnés à la va
vite et elles représentent des femmes et
on a et elle son dessin très opulent des
fesses et des hanches très opulente
également et on les a mal lu ces
statuettes
on a toujours associé ça à un symbole de
fertilité en pensant que c'était des
statuettes on appelle maternité comme on
peut avoir dans dans l'art africain
en fait ces statuettes qu'on les regarde
bien c'est les fesses qui sont gros ce
n'est pas le ventre c'est pas des femmes
enceintes qui sont représentés le ventre
souvent pas sûr c'est sur ces statuettes
et donc plus c'est plus des images si
vous voulez érotiques ou de corps nus
que de fertilité de maternité et et puis
l'idée d'un culte d'un mythe ça suppose
qu'on les retrouve dans des lieux clip
temple je ne fais pas de culte dans une
cuisine or toutes ces sept ses
statuettes le contexte découverte c'est
ça qui intéresse et archéologue sait où
est ce qu'on retrouve les objets souvent
elles sont retrouvés cassé
en miettes dans les habitats oui donc là
bon ça ça questionne vraiment le la
manière dont on lit les objets hors
contexte parce qu'on les regarde dans
des musées donc on se refaire quelques
clotilde eux tu disais tout à l'heure
que même si ça ne réduisez pas la
qualité de l'ouvragé parfois l'écriture
était un peu rapide un peu en sont l
enthousiasme aussi peut-être la célérité
dans l'écriture comment est ce que tu
peux nous en parler d'un réception de ce
livre est ce que parce que forcément
quand on parle de deux objets d'objets
dont on est séparés grandement il ya
forcément une couche d'interprétation
une imagination aussi prend le relais
parfois c'est important dans la science
de faire preuve d'imagination
est-ce que parfois on a reproché à
l'auteur de ce livre donc de alain
testart de d'en faire un peu trop dans
l'interprétation est ce qu'au contraire
il a été relativement suivi est ce que
c'est plus un ce1 et c'est donc sur
lequel s'exerce et lui-même aussi sur
lequel il exerçait sa propre pensée
aussi comment comment a réagi me noté
scientifique en fait les l'oeuvre
d'alain testard elle est toujours assez
bien a déjà n'est pas connu du grand
public mais elle est beaucoup des
spécialistes et c'est quelqu'un qu'on a
beaucoup admiré
chez les archéologues parce qu'il avait
une curiosité et parce que justement il
était généraliste et on a un problème en
archéologie c'est qu'on a que des ultras
spécialistes et qui n'arrive pas à tirer
de deux de vision plus globale voilà de
créer des paysages et pour pour ce
chapitre là en l'occurrence il est bien
il est bien reçu des archéologues parce
que ça n'a pas vraiment de surprise ça a
été mal reçu par contre pour ceux qui
qui soutiennent la thèse d'un matriarcat
primitif etc et c'est dommage parce que
parce que croire au matriarcat croire au
matriarcat c'est vraiment faire le jeu
du patriarcat donc c'est vraiment c'est
un cercle vicieux qui est pas très très
intéressant et voilà moi j'ai choisi les
deux livres que j'ai choisi il
questionne vraiment la représentativité
l'image la fabrication des images et il
se fit se répondent
le deuxième livre que j'ai choisi oui
c'est un best-seller de 2018 qui a été
écrit par mona chollet qui s'appelle
sorcière la puissance invaincu des
femmes et saha livre que au départ j'ai
un peu boudé du pas du tout voulu aller
l'intérieur c'est parce que c'était un
best-seller ouais peut-être un peu
c'était surtout le titre nous voilà
encore sorcières c'est encore un truc
comme si les femmes si les livres
d'histoire pour que ça intéresse les
femmes ça prouvait que traiter de ce
sujet là et je suis quand même allé et
il se trouve que c'est un ouvrage qui
qui qui qui est incroyable et s'il ya un
seul livre à lire sur le thème des
sorcières c'est celui ci parce que
justement il est très habile
parce que les sorcières c'est qu'un
prétexte à l'autriche pour parler
d'autres sujets pour par exemple de quoi
il doit justement se livre alors il
parle il ya tout un premier chapitre sur
la chasse aux sorcières bien évidemment
pour voilà contenter le lecteur qui a
acheté le livre donc c'est toute une
partie sur les période médiévale et puis
ensuite ils l'ouvrent sûr
la solitude l'indépendance de des femmes
et sur justement c'est pour ça que ça
fait écho avec le livre de thé star sur
le mythe de la maternité a même
l'institution de la maternité qui abat
parfois et subit et c'est absolument pas
c'est un discours qui est très marginal
dans la société
donc là ça fait du bien par une femme
qui est plutôt aux jeunes encore
d'entendre ce discours et qui finalement
se ce cette maternité comme au mondial
réussite de la vie des femmes et pièces
complètement le destin et la volonté de
toute une partie de la population et
ensuite elle va ouvrir sur un sujet qui
est essayé de répondre à la question
comment on peut accomplir sa vie comme
l'ont fait les hommes depuis les siècles
et comment on peut le faire après des
siècles de sacrifices et par sacrifice
et longtemps la chasse aux sorcières et
donc c'est au final mois la conclusion
quand je les lui elle ne dit pas
vraiment mais la leaf et échos c'est une
critique de la mère nature qui est ça
fait vraiment écho à ce qu'on peut voir
sur les réseaux sociaux notamment les
réseaux sociaux qui sont très très
regardé par les femmes comme instagram
notamment qui servent complètement sur
ce mythe là sur le mythe du matriarcat
sur la puissance politique et économique
et tant qu'il ya cette croyance là bas
on tourne en rond parce que c'est une
elle vient expliquer que allah à la
source de la de la mère nature bayadh et
il ya un catholicisme qui est très fort
parce qu'on se repose sur l'unique
uniquement biologique et on oublie
totalement la dimension sociale et
culturelle d'un individu est finalement
basse sa liberté c'est une fierté de
faire des choix
voilà donc c'est franchement ces deux
livres je pense que celui des stars est
encore plus féministe que tous les
livres qui existent sur le féminisme
actuellement c'est dommage parce qu'ils
manquent tous les manques cruellement à
la bibliographie de tous les livres
féministes et de toute façon
l'archéologie anthropologie c'est
dommage il faut je pense que toutes les
sciences humaines et sociales
vraiment intérêt à aller chercher du
côté de l'archéo des idées stimulante
est-ce que c'est des livres qu'on peut
conseiller à des gens qui n'ont aucune
connaissance archéologique ou en tout
cas qui n'ont pas de culture
voilà moi souvent corps me demande
comment quel livre archéo tu conseilles
pour débuter chaque fois je cite testard
parce que parce que l'écriture elle est
limpide
c'est de la vulgarisation jeu c'est
difficile de conseiller lévi-strauss
sais c'est difficile à lire ça alors que
les stars c'est puis cdc des livres où
il ya déjà beaucoup de photos il ya
beaucoup d'image tout est appuyé par
l'image et cholet sorcière bas pour
franchement on l'a vu en 2019
il ya une quantité ya un lectorat
féminin qui ne lit jamais d'histoire et
qui s'est mis à l'histoire via ce livre
et c'est juste une porte d'entrée on se
dit bas à partir de ça ou pour aller
lire du michel perron et qui peut-être
après je ne sais pas henri guillemin
pour n'importe quoi mais c'est ça on a
vraiment besoin de ces livres notamment
pour pour l'histoire qui vraiment un thé
qui est teintée par par les guerres et
donc il ya toute une partie de la
population dont les femmes qui disent
pas du tout merci vraiment beaucoup
clotilde et l'audit a peut-être une
question ou une rumeur non j'ai bu les
paroles de clotide voilà merci vraiment
beaucoup clotilde d'avoir participé à ce
live pour nous pousser ces deux
recommandations
on retrouve les les liens vers ses
ouvrages dans le chat et puis il y aura
un article un bien sûr récapitulatif de
ce qui paraît très grands labos la
semaine prochaine et en fera évidemment
l'inventaire de tous les livres qui ont
été présentés et bien sûr bien sûr il y
aura la couverture et le lien vers ces
deux ouvrages et pas un lien vers cette
grande plateforme dont le nom commence
par un a bien sûr mais un lien vers les
bibliothèques
ça c'est fait merci beaucoup clotilde
mais c'est une très belle continuation
pouvoir en tout de suite bien sûr sur la
chaîne youtube assez sauvage voilà l
audi ont déjà déjà à la fin quasiment on
a fait un spot not least
quelqu'un qui va également nous proposer
de lire de livres coups de coeur ouais
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs c'est bien parce
que je trouve que un des deux livres
qu'elle va nous proposer le sujet a pas
encore trop été abordé à découvrir ça
tout de suite avec 6 il n'y donc avec
lorca russo salut nord salut merci pour
l'invitation
merci à toi d'avoir accepté est ce que
tu peux nous parler de science infuse
avant de nous parler de ta sélection
évidemment une vulgarisatrice
scientifiques déjà chevronné oui alors
science infuse en fait pour précisions
c'est le nom de notre site science
infuse moins cool d'aia mais en fait moi
je fais un podcast avec un ami qui
s'appelle savant sachant chercher et
prononce bien parce qu'il est à présent
temps j'allais ouais c'est mieux quand
il prononce toit en fait mais ouais je
pense que c'est peut-être parce que je
les prononcer beaucoup de fois refait le
voir comment refait le voir c'est avant
sachant chercher ses dires mais après ça
parfaitement ouais en fait on du coup
d'interviews des acteurs de la recherche
dans vraiment plusieurs domaines de la
science
donc à chaque fois c'est un épisode par
mois on vulgarise une notion
scientifique avec l'invité
on parle ensuite de ses recherches et
puis après il ya des questions aussi un
peu plus générale de autour de la
culture scientifique
comment est ce qu il voit ses recherches
dans le futur etc
et voilà et on retrouve ça sur apple
podcasts ou ouais c'est sur toutes les
plateformes de podcasts et sur notre
site aussi la science infuse pour un
super on renvoie le lien bien sûr dans
le chat et on retrouvera tous ces liens
là dans la pratique alors tu es venu
avec deux livres comme des autres ouais
tout à fait il fallait pas le premier
alors le premier c'est ce que j'appelle
un peu ma bible c'est le kop de la
conscience de stanislas de haine qui en
fait je me suis intéressé il ya quatre
ans je travaillais sur les un moment sur
les états de conscience modifiée
notamment
le commun et du coup en faisant des
recherches le rapidement tombé sur
stanislas dehaene qui travaille sur la
conscience comment mesurer la confiance
entre autres et ce bouquin du coup est
vraiment tout un hymne à une vaste étude
bibliographique sur tous les travaux qui
ont été faits pour qu'est ce que la
confiance
qu'est ce que la conscience qu'est ce
que le libre arbitre l'inconscient
comment est ce qu'on mesure tout ça
aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue de neurosciences et
c'est vraiment ses fins en fait ce que
j'aime bien c'est que j'ai appris plein
de choses alors que j'avais déjà un peu
des connaissances quand même en
ressources mais j'ai vraiment appris
plein de choses et que souvent je me
replonge pour avoir voilà des détails
sur une étude en disant c'est pas ou sur
des méthodes d'imagerie cérébrale
puisque c'est quand même vraiment ça qui
a permis aussi de comprendre de
comprendre plein de choses sur la
conscience d'aujourd'hui est une des
choses que j'ai vraiment appris aussi
que j'ai bien aimé c'est qu'en fait il
explique avec toutes les équipes qui a
eu et qu'il a fait aussi qu'il ya tout
un traitement inconscients qui est fait
par notre cerveau en permanence dont on
se rend pas compte mais qui est
nécessaire pour garder ce qui est
important pour nous juste du coup pour
qu'on puisse ensuite traités que les
choses de manière consciente que les
choses importantes
et voilà du coup ça mais j'étais
vraiment intéressés par un peu c'est
question de comment viennent les
perceptions les pensées il ya aussi une
partie sur les 1 petit peu sur les rêves
auxquels je m'intéresse beaucoup
donc voila moi j'ai une petite question
sur l'accessibilité degré du lga
risation alors j'essaye d'être objective
bah franchement moi je n'ai vraiment lui
d'une traite et en comprenant vraiment
tout et je pense que même s'il ya des
petits détails où il ya des mots
peut-être un petit peu technique où il
va rentrer dans les détails de voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe dans les neurones
etc
dans l'ensemble c'est vraiment
accessible après ça reste assez
technique
voilà c'est il présente les études
comment est-ce qu'on en arrive et c'est
là et c'est donc c'est pas une histoire
c'est pas voilà un roman c'est quand
même un essai mais je trouve que c'est
vraiment accessible je dirais je sais
pas si on a des gens qui en bavent plus
bas de suite et puis c'est bon non mais
c'est vrai que parfois en fait on voit
ça avec les bouquins de science c'est
que il ya deux lectures
il ya deux niveaux de lecture ya le
niveau de lecture de on n'a pas de
connaissances et du coup parfois ils
vont un peu partir sur des mini truqué
et c'est pas les plus importants donc on
comprend le bouquin au final même si on
comprend pas tous les détails
et puis le niveau de lecture où on
comprend les tous les détails et on pas
ce qu'on voit là quelques connaissances
mais là c'est vraiment enfin moi je
trouve que même en leur lisant
maintenant comme je disais je vais
souvent des fois piocher un peu pour
dire une information particulière je
trouve que justement c'est quand même
c'est quand même vraiment accessible à
ceux qui s'intéressent à comment comment
quelle est la signature célébrer de la
conscience mais aussi ça apporte
évidemment des questions sur voilà
maintenant qu'on sait ça qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait il ya des réflexions un petit
peu plus j'allais dire philosophique
aussi après il ya toute une partie à la
fin qui est intéressante sur le lien
avec les machines intelligence
artificielle et ça c'est clairement
accessible à tous
tu nous rappelles tu as spécialité ta
formation moi j'ai un doctorat en
physique appliquée aux neurosciences et
à bout cette appétence pour les ouvrages
oui oui une cerveau exactement c'est ça
d'ailleurs j'ai hâte de lire le livre
alors à elite apprendre à rire le truc
c'est que c'est vraiment les bases du
cerveau pour des gens qui n'y
connaissent rien qui n'en n'ont pas quoi
voilà non non je plaisante
vague de blagues de merde mais il est
tard maintenant mais c'est vrai il ya un
deuxième livre qui quittent a vraiment
marqué l'or dont tu peux nous parler
peut-être maintenant si tu veux ouais
tout à fait c'est ce livre juste pour
placer le contexte je les lui l'an
dernier bien qu'ils essaient battre
candidate mais il ya déjà quelques
années je travaillais un petit peu avec
une amie qui prépare un kit rappellera
un film sur notre aux physiciens entre
autres et du coup on a on a commencé à
parler un peu de science et c est en
fait je me suis dit que vraiment je ne
connaissais malgré ma formation un
physique je ne connaissais vraiment pas
grand chose sur l'astrophysique et du
coup j'ai je me suis plongé dans
poussière des toiles de hubert reese est
en fait c'est vraiment j'ai eu vraiment
plaisir à lire parce que déjà d'unia les
superbes photos c'est un peu mon dos et
ça compte pas sur l'astre aussi les
photos ça ouais en fait ça m'a surtout
amené à passer vraiment des heures
vraiment des heures sur le site images
de la nasa et de beule à huy où j'ai
fait imprimer des photos après fin
c'était la cb poster est en fait du coup
ça nous parle de voilà de la formation
de l'univers de ça donne une
cartographie de l'univers des galaxies
de commandes as les étoiles comment elle
meurt de quoi elles sont faites et aussi
sur la vie en général
d'où vient la vie que ça vient aussi de
la mer qu'est-ce que dans les deux sens
du terme
qu'est-ce que comment est ce qu'on en
arrive à à se dire enfin est ce qu'il ya
de la vie ailleurs la question que voilà
donc ce coach tous est ce que j'aime
bien dans ce livre c'est que je pense
que n'importe qui s'intéresse un peu à
la cense en fait pour trouver là dedans
vraiment son compte parce que ça parle
de biologie d'astrophysique dépit de
manière complètement accessible et avec
spa des photos par exemple enfin je vous
montre juste ça c'est quand même c'est
quand même assez sympa donc voilà si
c'est un livre assez court
il n'est pas c'est pas les normes pavés
c'est pas énorme pavé ces petits
appareils à défaut je relis de petits
bouts et en fait j'ai vraiment appris
mais plein de choses et puis surtout
j'aime bien le aussi l'aspect il donne
pas mal de deux chiffres sachant que
c'est quand même des on parle quand même
de l'univers cd des dimensions qui en
tout cas moi je
ça me parle pas vraiment et en fait là
il donne vraiment des chiffres de
manière tout à fait compréhensible et
finalement ça fait un peu j'ai à dire
c'est un peu bisounours que je dis mais
ça fait vraiment dire à la fin quand on
finit le livre je suis dit quand même
c'est vachement bien foutu et eu leur
idylle et il est fantastique il est très
très très bon pas juste pour l'astro
mais pour lier tous en fait quand il se
met à parler du monde
enfin tu as juste envie de l'écouter et
voilà et qui s'arrêtent pas en fait il
est passionnant et ça fait partie de ces
gens qui ont été vraiment les premiers
en tout cas dans l'époque récente
apparaître comme d' authentiques
vulgarisateur de science non je pense
que tu en penses elodie ouais les
grandes figures comme ça les grands
passeurs de science tout de suite quand
tu demandes aujourd'hui encore substance
très vite à hubert reeves oui tout à
fait et d'ailleurs c'est vraiment le fin
ça m'a fait penser quand j'ai lu le
livre de ce genre justement de grandes
oeuvres en personnage allait dire
presque 2 en une phrase on va comprendre
des concepts que que voilà enfin j'avais
je me rappelle d'un cours pendant mes
études que je suis vert en cardiologie
jeu indé lui est en fait c'était il ya
vingt membres entrer vraiment dans les
détails moi j'étais un peu perdue parce
qu'il y avait des bases que j'avais pas
et un jour je crois que chabrol et et
qui nous qui parce que le prof était pas
là il nous a donné un cours est en fait
il a dit laissez tomber cahiers stylos
et en une heure il nous a expliqué avec
plein d'anecdotes histoire de la
médecine la cardiologie etc
et finalement on avait compris beaucoup
plus que en 18 heures de cours
et là j'ai vraiment eu l'impression que
c'était pareil en mairie
voilà franchement en un livre alors oui
un livre mais il fait passer des
concepts comme contenait beaucoup de
connaissances et on va vite vite
comprendre
donc voilà c'est cabrol pas chabrol
c'est juste à redon c'était ce week-end
à cause de moi parce qu'un film de
chabrol hier sportenum mais c'est parce
que c'est à cause de moi mais je n'ai
cessé de dire merci merci vraiment
beaucoup d'avoir participé à ce live
lors c'est très chouette
qu'est-ce qu'on peine à gazon qu'est-ce
qu'on peut annoncer s'agissant de ta
série de podcasts prochain épisode c'est
qu'en sachant chercher du coup le
prochain épisode c'est dans une dizaine
de jours c'est un hors série peut pas en
dire plus peut-être mélodies deux ans et
ça et noir n'ont maintenant y'a pas moi
dedans parce qu'un podcast sans mélodie
dedans moi je sais pas monsieur ça veut
pas ça existait en fait non non je
rigole parce que le dit travailler avec
le l'invité du futur podcast c'est sur
l'adaptation d'accord voilà
ok le maquis fait d'accord mais
l'adaptation ça peut tout vouloir dire
donc fait jamais c'est avec ces avec à
un explorateur français christian clôt
je peux quand même dire dire le nom de
quoi et qui du coup voilà en fait on
fait un petit hors sujet sur comment
avec toute cette période qu'on traverse
comment est-ce que l'homme s'adapte à
des échanges des gros changements
mais voilà c'est un spécialiste des
situations extrêmes et donc il a monté
un institut d'adaptation qui étudie donc
scientifique d'étude de l'adaptation au
milieu extrême est typiquement bas ce
genre de crise ce genre de situation ces
extrêmes voilà donc il bosse là dessus
ça va être super intéressant à suivre
donc dans une dizaine de jours dans
chercheur nom savant sachant chercher ce
avant sachant chercher s'avance sachant
chercher c'est facile va alors elle plus
leur merci beaucoup merci la royale
merci à vous ciao
voilà elodie c'est déjà la fin de ce
live dans quelques minutes c'est vrai
qu'on prenne un peu de temps pour parler
pour finir de ton at on un petit bilan
de cette session qu'est ce que tu as
quelques est-ce que tu lire est parmi
tous les livres qu'on a cité qu'est ce
que tu qu est-ce qu éventuellement tu te
garderai je crois que tu as bien flashé
sur la testa où je le tronc ouais ouais
ouais sur pierre simon laplace quand
même ouais c'est le plaisante
non mais ça aussi ça me donne bien envie
mais en fait le problème c'est que je
dis je dis pas des milliards de bouquins
par mois donc du coup si tu veux en
choisir un dans la liste science books
la good book ce serait lequel tient à
les bonnes questions
alors on n'a pas eu le temps de donner
les tient par contre mais oui c'est vrai
je vais faire ça en 30 secondes
alors pendant que réfléchie tu veux
ouais vas-y fais-le alors moi pendant
que pendant que elodie choisi son livre
à garder parmi toute cette sélection là
je vous parle également de bande
dessinée avec ce livre qui est connu
c'est une bande dessinée qui a paru
l'année dernière
donc c'est jean-yves du ou dans le
secret des labos publié chez dupuis
c'est tout les tous les récits de diou
donc ce dessinateur qui va à la
rencontre des chercheuses et des
chercheurs dans leurs bras dans leur
laboratoire c'est des récipients qui
sont parues ces dix dernières années
dans spirou et c'est vraiment un modèle
du genre presque déjà un classique pour
moi sur sur l'aspect communication
scientifique vulgarisation scientifique
et dessins il tient très bon très juste
milieu entre un dessin fidèles qui
passent du temps à reproduire des
laboratoires des matériels des
dispositifs et des blagues aussi pas mal
d'humour - bien sûr c'est pas du marion
montaigne donc vous attendez pas si vous
aussi vous le lisez à retrouver un style
proche de marion montaigne c'est
peut-être plus sérieux mais il ya
également pas mal de petites blagues et
c'est très très très pédagogique
typiquement si vous avez des enfants des
ados qui peuvent un peu sur sur les
sciences c'est une très très bonne très
bonne entrée dans l'est ce dans le
secret des labos de jean yves duhoo on
retrouve
je n'ai d'ailleurs chroniqué dans grands
labos j'ai fait un article avec avec lui
enfin je l'aï interviewé donc il me
parle de son de son travail
on retrouve ce jeu vous mettra le lien
dans le chat pour retrouver l'article
sur grand labo avec donc cette interview
de jean yves duhoo et puis le deuxième
là aussi ouvrage que vous présentez
c'est aussi une bande dessinée s'est
fait conjointement avec antonio
fischetti et bouzar antonio fischetti
c'est un journaliste scientifique qui
travaille beaucoup pour le canard
enchaîné et qui en une page présente un
chercheur ou une chercheuse et c'est
vraiment génial parce que c'est à la
fois drôle qu'on s'y est même temps on
retient des idées simples s'agissant des
parcours principaux sur lesquels des
travaux principaux de chacun des
chercheurs et des chercheuses d'or
forcément beaucoup plus de chercheurs
que deux chercheuses hills en justifie
dans sa dans sa préface il explique
pourquoi il la suit l'histoire
officielle des sciences et s'est
illustré par beaux-arts qui est
d'habitude un dessinateur un peu dégueu
lagos qui a plus l'habitude de faire des
choses comme ça parfois un peu pipi caca
même donc plus dans le style edika donc
ça c'est du bozar d'habitude on gaza
pour le coup c'est un pastiche de lucky
luke où il fait des choses comme ça où
il parle de sa vie un peu en monnaie ou
les beaux-arts
il raconte ses exploits dans son
quotidien qui est vraiment pas toujours
folichon folichon et donc en fait ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans cet ouvrage
je rappelle le titre la planète des
sciences la planète des sciences
encyclopédie universelle des
scientifiques parues chez dargaud jeu
que j'aime beaucoup dans cet ouvrage
c'est la combinaison réussie je trouve
entre le style de bouzar et le ton
l'écriture la qualité d'écriture et de
synthèse de antonio fischetti voilà pour
mes coups de coeur
ça c'était du pitch à toi donc qu'est-ce
que tu vas c'est hyper dur en fait
j'arrive à en sortir une seule pour être
honnête
alors déjà les deux tiers ne me plaisent
pas mal mais bon ça on va les mettre de
côté parce que j'ai pas eu le temps de
réfléchir trop mais ça a l'air bien en
bd franchement une pardon ça me tente
bien écoute je pense vu qu'en ce moment
je suis très lecture cerveau parce que
bon voilà je pense que le bouquin de
l'est être bien dans sa peau il
m'intrigue en fait on ne t'entend plus
mathieu tu vas revenir je vois moi on
s'est pas passé et moi je sais ce que
j'aurai retenue ouais bon tu en as well
il m'intrigue parce que je me dis ça
peut être intéressant de voir justement
toutes ces études qui ont été faites
tout ça c'est un peu cerveau justement
et biochimiques donc bio cerveau dirait
que ça me donne envie
ouais je pense c'est
ce sera celui-là ça serait celui-là mais
après le truc c'est que honnêtement
cette liste enfin ça ils m'ont tous
donné on dit donc c'est ce serait pas la
fin des journées qui dure soixante douze
heures ouais enfin voila mais c'est stop
et ça m'a permis aussi parce que là du
coup être bien dans sa peau c'est un peu
de la bio un peu de la neuro mais
effectivement les bouquins de clotide ça
m'a donné envie aussi et ça serait
vraiment des trucs verts lesquels je
serais pas allé d'habitude parce que
c'est un peu en dehors de ma zone de
confort et un peu en dehors de mon
habitude aussi de consommation donc de
bouquins donc j'avoue que c'est bien
justement ça c'est intéressant de voir
ça je me dis pas pourquoi pas aller sur
des trucs un peu différent
en tout cas j'ai été vraiment très très
heureux de faire ce live avec toi et le
dis franchement ça m'a fait très plaisir
c'était vraiment chouette on redonne
juste deux petites actu tôt concernant
parce que il ya peut-être des gens qui
nous ont rejoint au cours du là elle
conte repas eu toute toute l'info ou qui
ont raté cette info là d'abord le
festival line of sight repoussé et voit
la décision courageuse qui a été prises
dont tu rappelle les dates alors du 7 au
9 septembre
sachant que cette date c'est la même
donc pas innocent c'est un festival de
vulgarisation qui se passe dans les bars
je rappelle pour au cas où si des gens
ne connaissent pas parce que c'est tout
le monde ne connaît pas encore donc on
va voir si on peut le faire du 7 au 9
septembre
si tout va bien on croise les doigts on
pourra le faire mais surtout c'est un
festival qui se passe dans plein
d'endroits ans en même temps en france
donc l'année dernière on avait cinquante
trois villes en france et à peu près 380
événement sur trois soirs donc il ya
vraiment plein de choses partout l'idée
c'est qu'il ya plein d'autres pays dans
le monde qu'ils font ces trois mêmes
soir aussi donc c'est ça vraiment le
truc cool c'est que c'est un ratio des
sciences un peu partout dans le monde
voilà et donc du 7 au 9 septembre c'est
la majorité des pays qui vont se
ce qu'elle est là dessus aussi donc
c'était une grosse décision
internationale qu'on a dû prendre du
coup voilà donc du 7 au 9
il y aura pas tous les pays très
clairement mais voilà on verra on verra
on suivra sa façon on te suit sur
twitter sur facebook
toi même et puis le compte officiel de
pinch of silent line of sight vais y
arriver deuxième petite info deuxième
petite info c'est dans ce livre sur
lequel tu travailles qui arrivera
l'année prochaine voilà aussi transformé
ouais le truc comme le disait le
coauteur travail en hôpital nous bon
voilà wayne on pense fort à lui est
d'ailleurs à tous tous les gens qui qui
sont en plein en pleine galère avec ça
avec ça écoute merci encore une fois
d'avoir participé à ce live peut-être à
l'occasion on s'en fera un autre sur ce
thème là ou sur un autre en tout cas
merci maman mille fois on suivait pas et
900 c'est elodie sur sur les réseaux
sociaux et je voudrais pour terminer
comme je le fais sur chaque live à
redire c'est important de respecter les
mesures de confinement que ça reste
important
et voilà ça ne mange pas de pain de le
redire donc voilà je le redis à rester
chez vous et puis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine samedi prochain à
14h30 avec un nouveau grand labo live
sur internet sur une thématique
totalement différente mais c'est ça
aussi le principe des live avec des
invités qui nous parleront d'autres
choses mais je garde pour l'instant le
suspense gentil gentil trop rien merci à
toutes et à tous encore une fois donc
d'avoir suivi 7,7 ce live on publiera un
article sur grands labos qui rappellera
les grands titres et les grands articles
les grands les grands livres présentés
au cours de ce live la semaine prochaine
d'ici là portez vous bien
salut elodie et salut à vous toutes et
tous salut tout le monde
ciao